so let's talk a little bit about our
friends on the left because I think
they've they've failed us but
particularly you and and your friends
and family probably in in this regard
they have somehow aligned themselves
with forces that don't want you to speak
up against doctrine and that's really
incredible it's the reverse of
liberalism
and I'll let you take it from there well
I mean that's what I think I think if
you're against bad ideas be against bad
ideas anywhere if you oppose homophobia
and you think homophobia is a terrible
thing it should be a bad thing and you
can point it out every time it's in
someone cost a Bible or every time it's
in a Donald Trump speech um you know or
a Ted Cruz speech or whatever it is then
it that same idea is also a bad idea
when it's in the Quran and if it's being
said by Muslims including a lot of
liberal Muslims I mean that is something
that even a lot of liberal Muslims in
North America haven't warmed up to yet
so these I understand like there's the I
think there's a instinct to try and
protect the minority but the ideology
that the minority here subscribes to
just coincidentally and I'm not saying
that they follow it the same way that
they do in other more violent parts of
the world but that same ideology the
same book is being used to kill people
right and to throw gay people off
rooftops in other parts of the world so
I think it's it is very confusing for
everybody because you know the way that
it happens is you know people see here
especially non-muslims they see on TV
they see a group called the Islamic
state quoting the Quran accurately and
actually saying quoting verses that say
fight the disbelievers and charge them
you know that the non-muslim talks and
you know God will destroy them and so on
so they're quoting these verses they're
saying Allahu Akbar
right so they're they're obviously
professing their faith and then they're
chopping someone's heads off or throwing
somebody off a rooftop and the reaction
over here often when they see that is
that they immediately jump to defending
the faith that this is their
faith and the moment they say that you
know you bring the scripture to them
you're like well what about this verse
they caught it just like you did with
your friend you know what about this
verse that they quoted it said this says
exactly the words that they said here
match the action and then they start
defending the verses and the book you
know misinterpretation out of context
and so on all the you know that's sort
of the excuses that you're here and so
now what you have is you have moderate
Muslims here defending the same book
that the fundamentalist over there are
quoting and citing to kill non-muslims
over there that the non-muslims are
looking at on this side of the world and
that is toxic because it actually makes
that gives the impression the moderate
Muslims over here are pretty much they
they subscribe to the same ideology
they're just not acting on it which is
not true well that impression it gives
not only is it not true but it seems to
me that people like you people like
Majnu oz Sara hater great people in my
estimation who I think are fighting for
the right things who are applying the
same principles across the board they're
not looking at your faith or your race
or your nationality they're saying here
are humanistic principles right that I
want to apply to everyone
the left is the one attacking them did
you ever expect that that was going to
be the pushback for you for me I know I
didn't honestly I mean I knew that there
were a lot of sort of moderate Muslims
that would have problems with it I just
didn't think that the sort of the CJ
Wellman's and the you know I guess you
know whatever we call the regressive
left Dave I can't keep track of all them
so this is just the one from most recent
memory you don't keep a list on the side
of your bed I have a chalkboard and I'm
just always adding to the list you don't
have that I I can't I have I have better
things to do I don't have enough time or
crayons to display I am spending a
fortune in chalk it's ridiculous no but
the the thing with regressive left and
on a serious notice
they're reacting to you know the
pushback that we're getting is a
reaction and for them I just look at
that entire thing is a very very
reactionary thing their only argument
only argument they have to anything is
bigoted islamaphobe house Muslim or you
know the brown skinned white eyed I
don't know what it was yeah it's a lot
of that there's that that's the only
argument that they have and I I I'm
actually encouraged I'm optimistic about
it I mean if you looked at in the past
every time one of these attacks happened
and there was some conversation to be
taking place on TV invited some on CNN
or MSNBC or fox or anything it would
always be when Reza Aslan could come on
or they'd call you know that the
comedian guy on CNN deemed so him and so
they would you know they that that's
what they would do but now I'm not
seeing that you know since these new
attacks and now that everything is
getting even more serious you know I'm
seeing more of Majin on TV I'm seeing
more of us starting to money on TV you
know I'm seeing voices like this I'm
seeing ayaan Hirsi Ali being called on
to talk about things so I I think that
most of the even the so-called
mainstream media is seeing through it
Bill Maher actually said on la shala he
was on or the one with Austin Imani when
he interviewed her he actually said that
he's more and more liberals are coming
up to him and agree with him they used
to get a lot of crops from in the floor
but he doesn't anymore
um and I think that that's changing and
I think that this hold that what we call
the regressive left is simply responding
to them well I gotta tell you I mean
that sounds incredibly uplifting because
you know I'm so in this and having these
conversations and as I said at the top
of the show I find a lot of it
exhausting and I battled sort of between
back and forth of light can I move on
from this topic and every time I move on
I feel like I get sucked back in and you
know I'll put it away and then I'll
suddenly see your your Twitter fight
with someone or I'll see you know
Greenwald attacking Sam or whatever it
is but
I think you gave me a little something
to go with there because the idea that
they are acting out more it's getting
more like a child having a tantrum and
maybe it's just because they realize
this is the last vestige of an ideology
that's just not going to work because
we've woke up right yeah I think that
they're they're prodding basically for a
response and do we give it to them you
know in all honestly a lot of times I
mean I'll ignore it for a while and I
and I die you know like with I'll ignore
it for a very long time but if I do
decide to respond inside response strong
and usually the response is not for the
person making it it's for the rest of
the audience for everybody else who's
watching the conversation and yeah I I'm
under no illusions that I can I can
change the minds of you know a lot of
these sort of hacks on that that are a
lot of the trolls that actually try to
you know dissuade us and try to deflect
everything but I think that for the
wider audience who's seen the
conversations it's good for them to see
what they're what they're dealing with
to see both sides of it and to see that
play out you know on whether on social
media or in books or in articles and so
on so I think that you know the you know
I'll give you I I think that they're
reacting to for instance with sam harris
you know sam harris has a lot of great
ideas he started a lot of really good
conversations in fact everything that
we're seeing right now with the rise of
Donald Trump and so the hijacking of
this conversation by the sort of because
the xenophobic paranoid side and now
them gaining ground and capitalizing on
on the on the fear and the concern and
the confusion that I think he's feeling
something that the left should have done
but they didn't do right and they should
have done it from a sort of a moral
honest position and now it's being done
by the right from a xenophobic bigoted
position this is something that sam
predicted a long time ago that you wrote
about it and now I I think you know
what's happening is that you know
there's all of these spats back and
forth with the green walls and where
almonds and you know
all of these other sort of characters
and they're deflecting from what was
initially the the actual thing that was
causing this response in the first place
right right
so what go ahead sorry no no I was just
saying we should continue with exactly
what we were doing before is what we
should be doing we should just be
talking about the ideas sticking to the
big picture I mean I came from when I
when I came here to Canada into the u.s.
after living for you know twenty four
years and in most of majority countries
I wanted to bring I want to talk about
big ideas you know I wasn't really
concerned about microaggressions or you
know regressive laughter you know all of
these other issues I actually wanted to
talk about the big ideas and and I've
noticed that the more a lot of us over
here are you know there are people who
try to pull us into these more sort of
petty Jerry Springer like conversations
and I think it would serve us best to
just ignore it
yeah well I listen I'm doing my best to
do that and I know I'm saying that
especially after what happened last week
so with me as well once in a while you
know well what once in a while I think
you have to do it and you have to have
look had all of this terrible stuff and
all of the slandering and all the stuff
not happened then I think the awakening
you know let's say you were awake
probably before I was I mean my real
awakening to this literally was that
that night watching Real Time with that
athlete thing so had it not happened I
may have been slumbering through you
know the left going further and further
to the left so in a weird way it is
actually very empowering but I that's
actually a perfect segue to I want to
talk about next what you're touching
upon which is that by not dealing with
this in an honest fashion by not really
allowing the people to speak about it
the liberals to speak about it in a fair
way you're handing this to Trump and
we're seeing this we're seeing this
right now in America we're seeing this
in Europe where for the first time ever
in places like Sweden and Denmark
far-right parties are running on anti
immigration because it's all
wrapped up in well we're afraid to be
called racist so it's crazy right yeah
they're they're all everybody's
Islamophobia phobic right yeah the fear
of being called a sound phobic and yeah
I think I think you're you're absolutely
right we did in a way hand this to trump
the the problem over here is that
there's Trump is not actually
responsible for all of this anti-muslim
hate and all this han time with some
sentiment that's happening so let's be
clear on that that the the party that's
responsible for that is the attackers
the the Isis the people who would talk
to parents of people who are making all
these videos of beheadings of you know
journalists and so on I mean these are
the people that the Americans and
Westerners in general are reacting to
right oh wait let me stop you there cuz
what would you say to my friends on the
Left who would say well it's America
that created Isis well America did there
it's obviously a complicated thing you
know US foreign policy there's u.s.
foreign policy there's nationalism
there's greed there's power there's you
know corporate oxi and all these other
characters that people talk about racism
and misogyny and people tell me they're
like you know why do you always pick on
religion when you have all of these
factors and I I always turn around I
tell them I'm like I agree with you they
didn't belongs right up there in the
same category with racism and greed and
misogyny and you know terrible things
that everybody else is doing so I do
think that US foreign policy is a factor
and the argument has never been that
religion is the only cause of religious
sentiments the only cause that we're not
asking people to recognize or to think
that it's not everything else it's
religion we're saying the only thing
that we're going against is the idea
that it's everything but religion to
ignore the religious aspect of it or the
fact that beliefs actually have
consequences because we want to respect
it so you are saying earlier is that
what Donald Trump is doing is that
there's a lot of confusion there's a lot
of fear that a lot of people have right
now legitimately
right the way that you channel that the
way that leaders channel that is
what makes all the difference you know
so Donald Trump has basically fed off of
it
he's drummed it up more for his own
opportunist opportunistic purposes and
he's turned into let's ban all Muslims
if there was another reasonable voice
you know on on the left and they had
channeled that and they had kind of
responsibly dealt with it in an honest
way then we may see a different outcome
you know when people confuse us when
leadership matters and that's where the
Liberals I think failed so that that's
interesting that naturally I agree with
that premise but I think you could
really take it to the candidates
themselves so for example Bernie Sanders
who I like a lot obviously and Hillary
when you take the candidates that are on
the left that are the Democrats when
they won't say Islamic extremism or they
won't say violent jihad or whatever
whatever the term you want to you know
everyone gets so caught up in terms that
I hate even using words at this point
but when they won't even say the terms
and they'll just say religious extremism
or something I think that that they also
then hand it to trump because trump's
just given you he's just giving you the
the wide you know the wide net to go
with and and they're still playing the
games of political correctness that's
exactly that that is kind of what I was
trying to say is that they do it so
there are there two things that have to
be done right now one is that the rights
of Muslims have to be protected and
number two Islamic doctrine has to be
challenged and criticized both of those
things have to be done what the what the
Hillary Clinton the Bernie Sanders side
is doing is they're trying to protect
all the rights of Muslims without
actually challenging the ideology and
what the Donald Trump on the right all
these people are doing is that they're
challenging the ideology without
protecting the rights of the people yeah
so yeah and and it's not an under people
think that that's contradictory it's not
contradictory at all this is what it was
Voltaire who said right like I I will I
may despise what you say but I'll defend
to the death your right to say it it's
the same principle and it's not that
difficult to do if we have a responsible
leader who actually does that I think
that that is something that a lot of
people would relate to and they would
understand
and that okay we will challenge doctrine
and a lot of Muslims they'll get hurt
like you know you're challenging my
religion this is my identity
people incorporate their beliefs into
their identity and the dialogue would be
well yes you're a person respect your
right to believe what you believe but
you know these are ideas ideas are
different we're talking about the ideas
we're not talking about you as a person
right so that if there was a political
party that was running you know that
said we're gonna throw gays off roofs
and we're gonna stone women and kill
apostates you probably be against that
political party but as a religion as a
religious doctrine it gets a little
extra credit or something that's that's
the thing like there's a lot of it
completely it would be that completely
strange things that we do for example
neonatal circumcision like infant
circumcision is one of those things
where you know we I mean my parents did
it you know my siblings have done it
like to their nephews and so on it's a
varied it's legal you know everybody
does it but when you really think about
it if there was okay if there was no
religion behind it or as I like to say
if Abraham didn't wasn't so fond of
[ __ ] you would say this would be
child abuse you'd have pediatricians
getting sued for this